ask any carer in the country the last
two years have been a constant battle to
keep covid away from the elderly and
clinically vulnerable for this care home
in bradford the fear is abandoning
restrictions now risks undoing all their
efforts that i think needs to continue
because again
many many outbreaks at this time but we
don't want to put our residents
in in a situation where which is
dangerous for their health
and well-being
we've been living with restrictions
since march 2020 months of full lockdown
rules of six two meters distance ten
days isolation working from home masking
and testing
cases due to omicron are still higher
than at any time in the pandemic the
only reason the government can gamble on
abandoning them now is because vaccines
especially boosters are keeping most of
us safe
but what about the announcement to end
the need for covert isolation possibly
sooner than march
if isolation is stopped then people who
are infected will go on to spread the
virus that is for sure our
recommendation is for isolation of cases
isolation and clinical care of cases to
continue because our goal is to prevent
onward spread and also the quarantining
of contacts we support countries in
reducing that time i don't say abandon
it but reducing that time
i put that to the health secretary
what is the public health justification
for ending the requirement to self uh to
self isolated
and if the government does bring that
forward is it prepared to do so against
the guidance of the who during a global
pandemic
it's reasonable to think just as
we're living with flu for example we
don't require people to legally
self-isolate but to remain cautious to
be sensible if they're infected we will
eventually have to find a way to live
with kovid in a similar fashion
perhaps we're in a position to learn to
live with it but what about the rest of
the world one of the architects of the
uk government strategy agrees some
restrictions can be lifted here but
argues omicron isn't much milder for
countries where vaccines have barely
reached
i think particularly in the uk we can be
cautiously optimistic i don't think
omicron will be the last variant the
rest of the world is still in a pretty
uh dire position you know numbers are
still going up in many many parts of the
world and until we resolve that problem
in 22 um we won't bring the pandemic to
a close globally now
there is hope however it's anticipated
there may be 20 billion vaccine doses
available worldwide by the middle of
this year
theoretically enough to allow the rest
of the world to start thinking past this
pandemic too
tom clark sky news